das ist wirklich eine wahnsinns meldung
aus china ein forscher behauptet die
weltweit ersten den veränderten babys
erschaffen zu haben
man habe das erbgut von zwei embryonen
gentechnisch so verändert dass die
beiden zwillinge resistent gegen hiv
seien bisher liegen noch keine
unabhängigen bewertungen des experiments
vor doch forschungsteams weltweit
geschockt denn fest steht solche
menschen versuche während der super gau
schlechthin falls sich diese behauptung
aus china bewahrheiten sollte hätte das
krasse folgen für die ethik und die
gesamte wissenschaftswelt und es hat
jetzt schon konsequenzen für die
beteiligten wissenschaftler
wissenschaftlerin welche jetzt mehr
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen konkret
geht es um den chinesischen forscher
jank juli von der southern university of
science and technology nist sehen er
behauptet in einem interview mit der us
presse agentur associated press dass
weltweit die ersten beiden
genmanipulierten babys geboren worden
seien dazu der wissenschaftler in einem
youtube-video zwei wunderschöne kleine
chinesische mädchen namens lulu und nana
kamen vor einigen wochen weinend und so
gesund wie jedes andere baby zur welt er
aber das neue allzweckwerkzeug der
gentechnik dass christa kassen neun
verfahren genutzt um die kinder
resistent gegen hiv zu machen was fakt
kurz noch amazon erklärungen der christa
karas neuen technologie kurz kurzbahn
über die wir hier bei gigs umsonst wird
ja immer wieder mal berichten die
methode revolutioniert gerade die
gentechnik denn mit ihrer hilfe lassen
sich ausgewählte gene einfügen
ausschalten oder auch umschreiben und
zwar sehr einfach es funktioniert quasi
so simpel wie eine schere mit ihr kann
die dna also das erbgut ziemlich
effektiv verändert werden
bisher gibt es beispielsweise versuche
krankheiten bei einzelnen personen zu
therapieren doch in den keimzellen von
menschen wurde sie bislang noch nicht
angewendet wenn das wären menschen
versuche und die sind verboten
das ist auch extrem gefährlich denn bei
dem verfahren werden auch immer wieder
andere bereiche des erbguts verändert
die eigentlich gar nicht verändert
werden sollen
das kann dann bedeuten dass
erbkrankheiten ausgelöst werden dass die
genmanipulierte lebewesen leichter krebs
bekommen können
und und und deshalb und aus ethischen
gründen sind menschen versuchen mit
chris packers neuen verboten und die
folgen sind noch weitreichender denn die
gentechnischen veränderungen sollten
nicht nur die nun geborenen zwillinge
selbst betreffen falls der plan von er
janko wirklich aufgegangen sein sollte
befinden sich die veränderungen in allen
zellen im körper der babys somit könnten
sie diese auch an ihre nachkommen
weitergeben inklusive der fehler
konkret soll der forscher mit hilfe der
christa klaß neuen technologie quasi
eine art eingangstor ausgeschaltet haben
über das das aids virus hiv
normalerweise in die menschlichen zellen
gelangt genauer gesagt geht es um das
gen für den sogenannten ccr5 rezeptor an
denen sich die viren für eine infektion
der zelle anheften bianchi juri
jedenfalls behauptet 16 millionen von
insgesamt sieben paaren mit der christa
klaß neuen methode behandelt zu haben
die mütter waren gesund die väter mit
hiv infiziert die embryos wurden per
künstlicher befruchtung geschaffen
elf der behandelten embryonen wurden
dann wieder in die frauen eingesetzt
wobei es letztendlich dann eben zu
dieser einen erfolgreichen
schwangerschaft kam laut dem interview
mit dem chinesischen forscher sei der
plan aber nur bei einem der zwillinge
wirklich erfolgreich gewesen bei dem
anderen wurde wohl nur eines statt der
beiden verantwortlichen gene
herausgeschnitten so dass eine infektion
mit hiv weiter möglich sei die am puls
angaben zufolge sei die
wahrscheinlichkeit aber hoch dass die
erkrankung nicht zu aggressiv verlaufe
wie gewöhnlich klar ist jedenfalls die
folgen dieser behandlung sind komplett
unbekannt und die zukunft der beiden
kinder somit vollkommen ungewiss
fachleute weltweit sind entsetzt denn
schließlich weiß man beispielsweise
nicht ob die herausgeschnittenen gene
vielleicht für andere wichtige vorgänge
im körper notwendig sind das experiment
ist zudem bisher nur in einem
chinesischen register für klinische
tests eingetragen mehr war auch nicht
zur behauptung yankees gibt es also noch
keine geprüfte wissenschaftliche
veröffentlichung genauso wenig wie eine
offizielle bestätigung von anderen
behörden und so rätseln fachleute aus
der ganzen welt was wirklich dahinter
steckt fest steht jedenfalls falls sich
diese behauptung aus china bewahrheiten
sollte hätte das konsequenzen für die
gesamte wissenschaftswelt und ihre ethik
die universität an der heag juli
arbeitet hatte sofort reagiert und
mitgeteilt dass man nichts von diesem
experiment gewusst habe man sei
schockiert und weiter heißt es dass die
entsprechenden experimente außerhalb der
universitätsstadt gefunden haben der
wissenschaftler habe damit ernsthaft
gegen die akademische ethik und
akademische normen verstoßen und auch
von anderen chinesischen kollegen und
kolleginnen erntet er janko große kritik
sie befürchten dass das ansehen der
chinesischen forschung damit zerstört
wird in einem protestbrief fordern sie
die aufsichtsbehörden auf schnell zu
handeln
zudem schreiben sie direkte versuche am
menschen können nur als verrückt
beschrieben werden es ist zwar möglich
dass die kinder die diesmal geboren
wurden für einen bestimmten zeitraum
gesund sind aber die potenziellen
risiken und schäden für die gesamte
menschheit die durch einen
ungerechtfertigten einsatz des
verfahrens in der zukunft entstehen
können sind unermesslich und auch die
internationale wissenschaftswelt ist
geschockt die sei ein affront gegenüber
der wissenschaft die voller
verantwortung zu diesem thema der
genmanipulation forscht heißt es
beispielsweise vom deutschen ethikrat
der vorsitzende peter dabrock sagt
sollte sich bewahrheiten dass ein mit
hilfe von christa karas 9
genmanipulierte sbb erzeugt worden ist
wäre dies für die wissenschaft ein super
gau
denn nicht nur in den usa und europa ist
es jetzt hat gesetzlich verboten einen
embryo gentechnisch zu verändern und
diesen dann einer frau einzusetzen damit
diese schwanger wird denn die risiken
derartiger manipulationen an
menschlichem erbgut sind bisher kaum
abschätzbar
hinzu kommt ja noch solche veränderungen
würden an nachfolgende generationen
weitergegeben
auch eine chinesische richtlinie von
2003 verbietet derartige forschungen
klar es bislang noch nicht ob der
forscher vielleicht eine
sondergenehmigung für seine versuche
bekommen hat fragen wirft jedenfalls
auch der zeitpunkt der veröffentlichung
dieser sensationsmeldung auf denn gerade
in dieser woche kommen an der
universität hongkong die pioniere des
genom editing zusammen zwar und zwar
beim second international summit of
human genom editing janke jedenfalls
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt von der kritik
und verspricht dass seine daten bald
veröffentlicht werden
er betont dass es ihm nicht darum geht
designer babys zu erschaffen solche den
veränderungen sollten
ein instrument der heilung sein bis die
gesamten daten seines versuchs
veröffentlicht sind kann nur spekuliert
werden ob tatsächlich die ersten gehen
veränderten babys zur welt gekommen sind
doch schon jetzt ist eines sicher eine
diskussion über diese art der forschung
ist enorm wichtig und es ist höchste
zeit sie jetzt zu führen bevor es zu
spät ist peter dabrock vom deutschen
ethikrat bezeichnet die forschung von
haye an qi jedenfalls ganz klar als
menschenversuch er betont die neben und
spätfolgen sind noch unabsehbar und
schwer zu kontrollieren die menschheit
muss ein mitspracherecht haben immerhin
handelt es sich um einen eingriff in die
biologische grundlage des menschen auf
jeden fall müssen alle beteiligten
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
jetzt sofort die arbeit an diesem
experiment einstellen
das hat das chinesische
wissenschaftsministerium jetzt bekannt
gegeben wir halten euch zu diesem thema
hier auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt dann abonniert auf
jeden fall auch den englischen kanal
hier werden auch da gibt es regelmäßig
videopremieren und darunter geht es
direkt weiter auf englisch fleckenstein
stars wie serge create human red hot
beans ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal zu tun
stay tuned